but first up he is the best-selling
author of giant of the Senate and the
junior senator from Minnesota a great
American Al Franken
[Applause]
[Music]
Al Franken great American giant of the
Senate it's so great to be able to see
you put out a book like that where
you're where there's irony right on the
cover yes you're allowed thanks for
realizing that many don't now there are
some oh oh don't write yeah but irony
yeah I know but but I want to ask you
because you are a senator and this week
bob corker among others have made
statements that we were waiting for them
to make for a long time what took people
like bob corker and other republicans so
long exactly I mean what's up so I've
known for weeks the Trump is a terrible
right
if you always out ahead out all right so
is this a turning point do you think I
mean we've said this before this you're
like I asked the question I I mean it is
this a turning point with how people
view and treat Trump even on the right
or will this be just sewn into his
horror quilt and in a month we have
forgotten it and we've moved past it
like we moved past [ __ ] grabbing and
everything else I just you know a lot of
people say now bannon's going because
that going to make a difference the
problem with this administration is
Trump and it's going to continue
so and we've heard this we've heard this
you know when Kelly comes in they'll be
in a battle everything will be fine and
then boom he threatens nuclear war
breath you know so and you know was last
week out that was I know that we've got
last week but I'm talking about Kelly
but I'm an you know but this this week
was unbelievably horrible this was a
tragic week and you know and Bannen on
his way out I was saying like well you
know Democrats talked about blacks only
one I mean just sickening it was just a
sickening week we three people lost
their lives this is but I don't I don't
think he changes this was Trump in all
I'm not asking about him we know he
won't change you're a senator you know
these senators you've made friend will
he's to make a difference in the 70s I
love the people who enable him that I
mean he's nothing without his enablers
well here's my there are a number of
Republican senators who have been saying
from the beginning that they have a lot
of doubts about him but who won't go
public with that because he still has 80
some percent of his base behind him and
that's their base so politically they're
unwilling to go public and there were
some people that said you know neo-nazis
there's nothing good about neo-nazis etc
but wouldn't blame Trump so no I don't
we are going to work in bipartisan ways
we're going to do it thank God the their
health care repeal and replace or
whatever that skinny thing was all went
down and we are going to work in a
bipartisan way Lamar Alexander's
chairman of the help committee health
education labor and pension committee
I'm on that committee patty Murray the
ranking member from Washington we're
going to work together to shore up the
exchanges so that we can make premiums
bring down premiums and bring down
co-pays and
cover people like they should be covered
and that's what we really get a
bipartisan and we're going to and after
and after that we should be addressing
pharmaceutical prices everybody here
everybody in the country knows I have I
use only street drugs oh I might never
go near pharmacy we know you're very
healthy and just but yeah I and and
don't need the pharmaceuticals but I see
people here who do and but but we pay
more than any other country pays right I
have a comprehensive bill to bring down
the cost of pharmaceuticals as the ideas
of a lot of senators and we will work
together and help committee to address
that and it's so interesting reading
your book I mean you are friendly with a
lot of these people who are you know
obviously politically on another planet
from you well they're just different
than they I mean that's we're presented
parts of the country there they shall be
what we're from the we're cut from the
same stripe I you know it's funny you
said something about you use the word a
pill if you're a pill people are not
going to work with you
I was like did I use that word
absolutely my mom used to do and my
mom's like I've never heard that word
except in your book and from my mother
yeah yeah well and I'm using this is
your like the anti-trump
he even the people who agree with him
politically now they hate him ii see
such a person yeah where they don't
remit you say Mitch McConnell Jeff
Sessions you like these people when your
ought you say enough about you you say
what you're only with them friendly well
that's what how is that different than
you like them when you're off the clock
now I agree with you politics I've
always said is an extension of morality
that's why I can't really quite
understand the Republican mindset but
you have to work together you that's
what you do and there are Republicans
that
very good to work with and I've done and
you look you're a small town here 100
people 100 senators I got to get along
with everybody in a small town and so if
I want to get legislation on on railroad
regulation with David Vitter I did a
bill with you know and her but I think
Bryn's huh the diaper guy yeah yeah yeah
and that that didn't figure into this
legislation at all when I first got
there I did a bill to get service dogs
to veterans with invisible wounds and I
did that with Johnny Isakson of Georgia
and he was my first co-sponsors bill got
done we got dogs to the veterans about a
month later we were at Teddy Kennedy's
funeral he we were doing this August
recess he said to me I've been getting
great feedback on this dog bill al if
you want me to co-sponsor anything just
let me know I said well I got a bill
it's a marriage equality abortion on
demand bill and he said I'll get back to
you but you have to be able to yes as
they always have talked to the other
side even when you don't like their
policy of course and if they let you say
the point is like when they like you
when you have those dinners we you said
you can make milk that was a joke I say
in the book that you know when we're I'm
not going to write things like when I'm
you know after had you know squabbling
on the floor Mitch and I will go out to
dinner and it'll laugh so hard that milk
shoots out is no I didn't that was the
joke yes I didn't think it really shot
out is
I've never gone out to dinner with Mitch
okay are you happy of that system fun
trying to give you a compliment and
blood your book and you're like oh oh I
never did those things well do it
directly did you like the book uh I
really did it's so great to see you
funny again so great to see you being
able to be funny again because well
there was a period there was a period
but you know when you when you see and
and of course the reason why you
couldn't is because you would worried
that Oh something in the past I said was
politically incorrect
now the Trump has broken all those
barriers it must look like why what was
I worried about obviously you could do
well it was it was a different time and
right when I ran in 2008 the Republicans
built this fifteen million dollar
machine called the D humor Iser right
and it was built with state-of-the-art
Israeli technology to take all the humor
out of anything I'd ever done in comedy
and just leave a pensive thing and so I
had to I thought being a comedian would
be helpful I thought people like company
I thought they did my career yeah but it
I had once I got to the Senate having
won by three or twelve votes I'm one of
the show the people Minnesota I was
serious it was going to be a workhorse
that's what I did yes next time I won by
over 200,000 votes absolutely and
absolutely and
and when you and Gavin newson are the
ticket for 2020 for president and vice
versa my plane was one you're going to
do even better I would break it
everybody how breaking
[Applause]